the OG crypto derivatives platform and
the best place to buy your Bitcoin
hey guys and welcome back to the Leia
plan show where we have some of the
hottest most taboo conversations that
you're sort of not allowed to have
anywhere else so I'm very excited for
today's guest but before I bring on my
guest please don't forget to hit the
like button and subscribe so you support
the channel as you never miss a video
okay so let's do this let's kick things
off because there's been a lot of stuff
in the news I want to unpack today so my
guest today he is a professor
evolutionary behavioral scientist the
author of multiple books including the
parasitic minds and the host of the
YouTube channel the sad truth if you
haven't guessed it it is God sad God
welcome to the show how are you I'm
doing uh great thank you so much for
having me
thanks so much for being here um like I
said before we went live um I've been
following a lot of your work your books
seen you on many different podcasts um
obviously The Joe Rogan one in
particular and I think you have a lot of
um really interesting things to say
about the crazy world that we're living
in right now so I'm I'm very excited to
have you
thank you thank you I look forward to
our conversation
all right let's kick this off because
I've seen a lot of weird things
happening in the in the media this week
and in particular was the
um the the campaign that came out from
Balenciaga so for those that don't know
Balenciaga put out this weird kind of
child pornography child bondage BDSM
campaign
um and and it's very strange and the
whole world is quite caught off guard
from this so firstly have you seen the
campaign
I've only seen exactly what you said
which is there was some kind of BDSM ad
with uh clearly a motif of a child but
that's about all I know about it
okay so I think what what shocked me was
that this isn't the first time we're
seeing children sexualized
we see this a lot with the whole trans
and drag queen Community
um I've seen you know drag queen Story
Hour and the funny thing is that there's
just not much outrage about this from
you know celebrities mainstream media so
I want to get your take on you know why
why are we seeing such silence when it
comes to children but we see outrage you
know when it comes to saying that men
you know men can't get pregnant only
women have periods like it's very simple
scientific scientific things like this
but when it comes to the sexualization
of children it's silent what's your take
on this why is this happening I mean
there are several ways by which one can
speculate why it's happening so I'll use
the following lines so when I'm talking
to my students about uh advertising to
children I will often tell them that you
know there's a there's a contradiction
in the following sense you're not
allowed to Target directly a child to
sell them some product because their
brains are not sufficiently formed but
you're able to Target them straight out
of the womb about your favorite religion
so there's kind of a a contradiction
here I can't sell you chewing gum until
you're 12 but I can tell you my favorite
religious narrative when you are one day
old and the reason I think for that is
because when I'm trying to sell you my
favorite religious narrative it is best
for me to access you when you are most
malleable when it is easiest for me to
be able to sell you this stuff so that
hopefully you become part of my religion
forever more you don't have the the
cognitive defenses that will allow you
to counter argue against my message so
if you were born in Mecca you become
Muslim if you were born in Italy you're
likely to be Christian if you're born in
Israel you like it to be Jewish and so
on and so I think that when it comes to
trans activism the idea is that we need
to normalize uh children seeing men
dressed as women who somehow become
women because then we are getting rid of
bigotry right so I think it starts off
with a noble cause right and that's why
you have things like twerking drag
queens well what's wrong with the you
know teaching children how to read in a
library while a drag queen is twerking I
don't necessarily think that it's coming
from a diabolical place at least in that
example to try to sexualize or groom the
children but I think that it's part of
the you know Grand effort to normalize
these things if I can convince a
three-year-old that it is perfectly okay
for some women to have nine inch penises
well then when they will eventually go
to some baloney liberal arts college
when they are 21 years old they won't
contest the idea that sometimes men can
menstruate as well so I think that's the
reflex where that comes from
yeah I understand that speaking to
Children about certain ideas when
they're young definitely
um instills a certain level of
indoctrination which you can't get rid
of just for context I I'm Jewish and I
went to a Jewish school in my life so
the indoctrination For the Love of
Israel is is powerful
um is is very powerful and it's
something that I that I realize now I'm
a bit older actually
um you know now I have the ability to
think for myself
um it's really really interesting
um but why but why are we at a point
where we can't say that's not okay
though like I understand about you know
pushing a level of equality trying to
normalize certain things but isn't it
just inappropriate like why can't we
have that kind of conversation I mean
certainly when it comes to children I
would say yes of course it's
inappropriate but again the more General
reflex I think it's that they are trying
to normalize certain things as part of
the you know it's my truth right so who
are you to say that genitalia determines
your biological sex and I and I know
that later we will get into to to my
last book but it really is part of all
these idea pathogens all of which start
off with a noble goal right so so I
don't think they originally start off
trying to be diabolical so for example
when it comes to militant feminism it
started originally as a good idea Equity
feminism was the notion that hey men and
women should be treated equally under
the law and I think most of us and all
your viewers would probably agree yeah
that makes sense the problem then comes
when you metamorphize that idea into in
the pursuit of seeking uh you know uh
equality between the Sexes we have to
argue that the Sexes are
indistinguishable from each other we
have to argue that all sex differences
could not be due to biological reasons
they must be part of social construction
so it starts off as a noble cause but
then it veers into lunacy because of
this original overriding Noble goal and
I always argue that I can chew gum and
why at the same time I could be fully in
support of trans people not being
discriminated against whilst also not
agreeing with the idea that boys too can
menstruate so I don't need to see the
millimeter of truth and the pursuit of a
noble goal
yeah that makes a lot of sense it just
it just blows my mind that we can't have
these open conversations and I want to
get your take would you say this would
have happened you know 20 30 40 years
ago and how how has Society changed in
that sense and do you think it's changed
for the better or for the worse well
certainly from the perspective of these
parasitic ideas you needed to have the
slow erosion of our edifices of Reason
in order to be able to be sitting in the
21st century talking about whether men
too can menstruate and bear children it
is so outlandish that to your point to
your question you know you had to kind
of soften the defenses the recent
defenses in order for these idea to be
palatable to most people right I mean uh
look uh Leia I I gave a testimony in
front of the Canadian Senate in 2017. at
the time it was regarding bill c-16
which in Canada was the bill that was
trying to incorporate gender expression
and gender identity
under the rubric of hate crimes and of
course I was perfectly in support of the
idea that nobody should be discriminated
against but again to my earlier point
that doesn't mean that we should be
arguing that men too can menstruate and
that men can have children and so on but
it is so important for people to defend
those rights that they have to slowly
eradicate our natural defenses against
such stupidity right and so I don't
think it would have probably found 40 50
years ago these specific idea pathogens
but this doesn't mean that in the past
we haven't succumbed to other lunatic
ideas in other words our capacity the
capacity for the human mind to be
parasitized has always existed except
that now we are falling prey to a new
set of parasitic ideas that's the
difference
and so what you're saying is that in
order to get to where we are today it's
been a slow gradual
um erosion of reality so where do you
think it first started well I hate to
say it because I am a professor but it's
uh it's the the culprits are the
professors who spread these nonsensical
ideas originally within the university
ecosystem so all of the idea pathogens
that I talk about post-modernism uh
cultural relativism social
constructivism militant feminism each of
these ideas were originally spawned in
some highfalutin Ivory Tower and when I
was warning people about this idea Paris
these ideological parasites the the
typical response I would get yeah sure
that sounds
as a form of lunacy but isn't it and
just some esoteric Department in the
humanities or in the social sciences and
then I would always tell them perhaps in
a prophetic way but these bad ideas will
eventually the break out of the lab
right just like the coven at least the
best of our knowledge is is a virus that
eventually you know broke out of the lab
these idea pathogens might start off in
a very constrained environment but
eventually they enter journalism and
human resources department and they even
become the prime minister of Canada and
so
so this this kind of dismissive idea
that I have often faced which is come on
stop stop screaming from the top of the
mountain about these idea pathogens it's
just some BS that's taking place in
University campuses well now we see that
you know bad ideas have Downstream
negative consequences
what confuses me is I understand that it
starts off as a noble cause
um like I I don't regard myself as a
feminist for example but I understand
where it came from and I respect that
and everything but I what I don't
understand is is why we're a point
whereby people can't just look at facts
in reality like when when did that when
did that break down you know like you
have the prime minister of Canada how
how is a prime minister endorsing
nonsense so I so
this so to to the answer to answer your
question I have to identify what I call
the granddaddy of all parasitic ideas
and that's post-modernism because
postmodernism is the epistemological
tool that allows me to argue that there
are no objective truths not one nothing
everything is Shackled by subjectivity
everything is Shackled by my
idiosyncratic reality everything is
Shackled by relativity uh and the and
and therefore it's precisely that quote
philosophical framework that allows me
to then say well of course some some
women do have nine inch penises what's
wrong with that that's totally feasible
and here I I'd like to maybe repeat a
story that I hope not too many of you
viewers have heard me mention elsewhere
but it's even worth hearing again
because it speaks exactly to your
question of how can we believe such
nonsense so in 2002 so this is 20 years
ago
uh one of my doctoral students had just
defended his his PhD dissertation and so
we were going out for celebratory dinner
and uh it was myself my wife him and he
was bringing along a date uh do you know
the story by the way no I'm I'm um okay
okay well good then it's even more
exciting to share it with you because
you haven't heard before uh so uh he
calls me up before the the that dinner
uh that on that day to to kind of give
me a heads up to say that the the lady
that he's bringing along for that dinner
uh is a graduate student in
post-modernism women's studies and
cultural anthropology to which I said ah
so the Holy Trinity of [ __ ] uh now
of course he was telling me all this
because you know his point was you know
let's let's have a fun time let's not
get into all of these rabbit holes I
said oh yeah no problem I understand
I'll be on my best behavior which of
course was a complete lie because I was
isn't going to be on my best behavior
and so about halfway through the evening
I turned to the lady in question and I
said so Europe you study postmodernism
correct yes so there are no Universal
truths no okay well I'm an evolutionary
psychologist so I do think that there
are Universal truths certainly when it
comes to human nature and so on so do
you mind if I posit a what I consider to
be Universal and then you could tell me
how I'm wrong she goes yeah sure go for
it I said okay is it not true that
within Homo sapiens humans only women
bear children now this is 20 years ago
so it's way before the transgender craze
uh is it not true that only women bear
children so she looks at me with
complete derision she can't believe that
someone could be such a simpleton she
says no of it's not true I said it's not
true that only women bear children she
said I said how is that she said well
because there's some Japanese tribe of
some Japanese island whereby within
their mythological folkloric realm it is
The Men Who bear children so by you
restricting the conversation to the
biological realm you know that's how you
keep us barefoot and pregnant so once I
recovered from the many strokes mini
stroke that I had at being exposed to
such stupidity I said okay well let me
perhaps then maybe it was too corrosive
it was too dangerous it was too
controversial to posit something as as
difficult to hear as only women bear
children let me give you another example
is it not true since time immemorial
that Sailors have relied on the
following uh cosmological reality that
the sun rises in the east
and sets in the west is that not true is
that not universally true so he or she
used a a variant of post-modernism
called deconstructionism and its founder
is Jacques de Rida the French
post-modernist philosopher whereby there
is no reality other than that that is
defined by language so there is no
reality outside of language so there she
says well what do you mean by East and
West those are just arbitrary labels and
what do you mean by the Sun that which
you call the sun I might call dancing
hyena I mean literally her words
verbatim okay so so I said okay well
fine then the dancing hyena rises in the
evening in the west and then she
answered I don't play those label games
so why do I always repeat that story
because it perfectly captures the the
intellectual terrorism of post-modernism
because if I can't agree with a graduate
student that only women bear children
and if I can't agree with the graduate
student that there is such a thing as
east and west and the sun then what can
we agree on right so this is why in the
book I talk about it being literally a
form of intellectual terrorism so to
answer your question in a long-winded
way it's
post-modernism is the bomb that brings
down the edifices of reason that then
allows me to believe anything because
it's my truth that matters there is no
truth with a capital T
let's get into why this is dangerous
because I I talk a lot about this and
people often say to me um oh you know
just let people be you know if they want
to if they wanna identify how they want
to identify let them be why do you have
to be so nasty Leia why do you have to
you know call people out why can't you
let them be and I I think it's because
it's dangerous but can you elaborate on
on why this idea is dangerous well look
it
if you wish to for let's say for example
transgender issues if you wish to
self-identify as anything you want
that's great if you ask me to go on the
journey with you and uniquely celebrate
your personhood I don't need to play
along right so for example I don't need
to be called a cisgender male no I'm
just male my wife is not cisgendered
she's a woman and I have a son and I
have a daughter so in the in the pursuit
this is what I call the tyranny of the
minority in my uh address to the
Canadian Senate right
point zero one percent of folks are
either transgender or non-binary or
whatever the the different appellations
that's great and they should be treated
uh with with all the due respect and
they should not be discriminated against
I'm all for that but in the pursuit of
celebrating your personhood I don't
eradicate mine so for example the idea
that we should no longer have on
passports uh are biological sex because
what if I'm non-binary and then you're
offending me so 99.9 of humanity has to
acquiesce to the point zero one so that
would be one example of how it's
dangerous it's dangerous to my
fundamental dignity right I I don't want
any harm to befall you and I want you to
be treated with all dignity but you
don't get to then force me to put
pronouns in my in my Sig in my uh
signature in my emails right I don't
have to play along so what now there's a
term of course that's called gaslighting
right so gaslighting is truly dangerous
because it attacks the most fundamental
nature of what is to be human which is
we've got this prefrontal cortex that
allows us to reason and when I now I I
am told with a metaphorical gun that you
have to agree that some women have nine
inch penises well that is attacking the
what it is for me to be a human being
that has the capacity to reason so if
for no other reason that's why it's
dangerous
yeah I I'm I also think that it's where
do we draw the line like if if we if
there's no fundamental truth anymore
then where do we draw the line
um you know I'm often hearing you know
I'm I'm very pro-female only safe spaces
despite the term safe space is being
ridiculous I mean I you know I don't
want men in my changing rooms I don't
men in my toilets um I think that's
dangerous for when I have children one
day
um and so for me I'm not sure why it's
it's and we see this all the time the
majority have to accommodate for the
minority
and and I think it's also because you
know you've probably heard things like
the progressive stack or you know I call
it uh victimology poker or you've heard
oppression Olympics this the argument
there is that there is a hierarchy of
victimology so for example yes uh women
who are in a rape shelter are victims
but their victimology score is not as
great as the transgender person who
wants to be in their space therefore
when the when these two victimology
narratives are pitted against each other
sorry raped women transgender woman
carries greater weight one of the
reasons why it's very difficult to to
come after me is because using that
victimology poker calculus I end up
winning always because I'm the childhood
War Refugee right who escaped execution
so there is Almost Never by definition a
victimology store story that you're
going to come up with whether it's a
real story or a manufactured one Allah
is molette that's going to outrank me so
if all else fails and you're whining
about your victimology while I pull out
my cards from my pocket and then you run
away like a little girl I see I don't
think I don't think you're at the top of
the higher the victim hierarchy guy
because I'm not gay because I'm not gay
because you're not you're not like dark
enough you're not gay you know like the
dark woman you've got dark enough let me
just say this I I mentioned this offline
before we started I'm looking
ridiculously pale especially if you uh
you don't want to see me when I have
about one percent of the amount of sun
that you currently have in Florida then
you might revisit those words
okay okay well right now you know right
now I'm a white supremacist I agree oh
yeah you're too much of a straight white
man right now absolutely not
um I want to talk about your book
um parasitic mind how infectious ideas
are killing common sense I I love the
that title which is it's it just sums
everything up so can you tell me about
some of the these infectious ideas that
are killing everyday common sense right
so I I mentioned already one
post-modernism that being the granddaddy
of them are social constructivism would
be another nefarious one so social
constructivism basically says that we
are all born fabula Raza empty slates
with no biological imperatives that are
built into our psyche with no
differences in our biological potential
and it is only social construction that
then makes us who we are so why do women
prefer certain types of men more than
others well it's because they saw it in
Hollywood images why do uh men prefer
certain types of women it's because they
learn what type of women to be attracted
to through Beyonce videos right so we're
Fabi La Raza right now again going back
to my earlier point about sort of the
how these idea pathogens start off as
noble goals
so what is the noble goal which which
such nonsense it is quite soothing Leia
for me if I'm a parent to know that
my child could be the next Lionel Messi
my child could be the next uh Albert
Einstein that that there is absolutely
nothing innately lesser about my child
any child could be anything that's very
hopeful message it's a wonderful message
but it's also also if you don't mind me
saying perfectly [ __ ] because we're
because I never had the same chance of
being an NBA star as Michael Jordan did
he's taller than me he jumps higher than
me maybe he will he he couldn't have
been as good a soccer player as I was
but the idea that we are all born with
equal potentiality and that it's only
social construction that makes us who we
are is simply nonsensical so that would
be another
idea pathogen cultural relativism is
another idea pathogen basically it says
that who are you to judge the the the
cultural belief system the cultural
values the the the patterns of behaviors
of another culture you have to judge
each culture within its own
idiosyncratic ecosystem of course that
can't be true so for example to your
earlier question when we first started
our conversation there should be some
absolute moral standards about how we
treat children everything is not
relative and it's precisely because
cultural relativism has seeped its way
into the psyche of many academics that
then we say but who are we to talk about
pedophiles being bad people aren't they
just minor attracted people have you I
don't know if you've seen that no I've
seen it I've seen it so that new label
that label is trying to normalize you
know there are different types of sexual
attractions some of us prefer fat people
thin people some of us prefer same-sex
some of us some some of us prefer
five-year-olds right so so again it
comes so it's that cocktail of idea
pathogens throw in a bit of postmodern
this them throw in a bit of social
constructionism throw a bit of cultural
relativism and then you get this
departure from reason that we see so
what I do in the book is I first Trace
where these idea pathogens come from the
University ecosystem and then I offer
toward the end of this the book
a mental vaccine against these Dreadful
mind parasites
can we talk about the mental vaccine
of course we can uh so uh there is a
long-winded answer and a shorter one
some of the some of the shorter uh ones
so for example the idea that most people
defuse the responsibility of fighting
back against this idea to others you
know got sad uh is strong enough he's
got broad shoulders He he'll speak for
me right and therefore I walk away from
an opportunity to engage in debate I'm
not talking about being nasty or mean or
impolite right but even if you're having
a conversation on Facebook or your
professor says something that's insane
challenge them politely at the pub on
Facebook on Twitter in your classroom in
other words don't defuse the
responsibility on a few others you know
who who have it on your behalf the other
thing that I will tell people and then
I'll come to the the more long-winded
answer
uh I always tell people as a call to
Arms is to activate your inner honey
badger the reason why I use that imagery
is because the honey badger is arguably
the most
Fierce and ferocious animal in the
animal kingdom it's the size of a small
dog and yet it can intimidate four five
six adult Lions how does it do that it
does it because it is extraordinarily
ferocious I mean really just go and
check it on YouTube now I ask people to
be ideologically fierce that doesn't
mean and polite it doesn't mean
threatened with violence but it means
that when I know
how to articulate a position good luck
to you trying to debate me that's I say
all the things that I say completely
unencumbered by political correctness my
career is concerns because I walk like a
70 foot tall honey badger not because
I'm arrogant not because I'm conceited
because when I know I know and when I
don't know I don't know right so I I
know I have epistemic humility when I if
you ask me you know what are the
downstream effects of legalizing
marijuana I would say you know Leia I I
don't know enough about this topic to
offer you an answer but when I know then
good luck to you if you wish to debate
me which now brings me to the
long-winded answer of how do you develop
a mind vaccine for truth
so here please bear with me as I set up
the the ground uh so in chapter seven of
the parasitic mind I have the chapters
titled how to seek truth and I argue
that you seek Truth by building
nomological networks of cumulative
evidence now that's a that that's a
mouthful so that means it is explain
what it is so let's suppose you you were
to ask me Leia uh all right uh our toy
preferences innate or uh are they a
social construction meaning that your
parents teach Little Johnny to play with
the truck and little Linda to play with
the doll and I would say that you know
they they're they are Universal
instantiation of sex-specific toy
preferences now what I'm going to do is
I'm going to build you that nomological
network of cumulative evidence
to demonstrate the veracity of my
position how do I do that I will do that
by getting you data
from across cultures that demonstrate
that that sex specificity happens in
exactly the same way so that's one so so
in the box of all the network that's one
data set cross-cultural universality
that enough that should be enough to
convince you but I'm not going to stop
there because I'm going to build that
normal logical Network that's going to
drown you in a tsunami of evidence so
number two I'm Gonna Get You data from
developmental psychology showing you
that children who are too young to have
been socialized in other words by
definition they could not have been
socialized to hold those toy preferences
they already exhibit those preferences
so that gets rid of the possibility that
those toy preferences were learned okay
so that's number two I can get you data
from other animals I can get you data
from vervet monkeys from rhesus monkeys
from chimpanzees showing you that they
exhibit the same sex-specific toy
preferences as human infants I can get
you data from across time periods I can
get you data from funerary monuments
from 2500 years ago in ancient Greece
and ancient Rome whereby children are
depicted playing with the toys exactly
as we would expect them today so what am
I basically doing metaphorically I'm
putting the epistemological Noose around
your neck
by providing you data from across
cultures across time periods across
species across disciplines all of which
triangulate into demonstrating that my
position is the correct one so the way
that you adjudicate between different
positions when you're debating someone
is that you hopefully have the cognitive
stamina to build that nomological
Network now my That vaccine that I just
offered hinges on one issue well two
issues number one the my interlocutor to
whom I'm trying to make that point can't
be going la la I don't want to hear it
because if they do that then all of the
normal logical Network in the world is
not going to convince you number two it
hinges on the fact that I need to be
sufficiently motivated to spend the
necessary effort to build that
nomological Network the problem is that
most individuals are cognitive misers
they're lazy therefore if if Barack
Obama peace be upon Him tells me that
Islam is peace then it's peace I don't
bother to actually conduct the
nomological network that would allow me
to adjudicate the position of whether
Islam is peaceful or not but so but that
notwithstanding
if my the person with whom I'm debating
is intellectually honest enough to grant
me the courtesy to show him my
homological network and if I am
sufficiently motivated to build that
normal logical Network that's how you
vaccinate yourself against [ __ ]
I think that having that that network of
evidence and facts is is key it takes a
lot of um cognitive effort and capacity
in order to in order to um do that and
provide that but you know I think I
think even that there is a lot of
information out there um and I think
people still you know like you said
refuse to um consider reality
um so I want to understand why do you
think that this mentality has such a
grip on people why are they easily
adopting these ideas
um and refuse to adopt better healthier
ideas like you know Jordan Peterson says
get your house in order make your bed
take personal responsibility you know
there's some really amazing speakers
that promote such incredibly useful
ideas and beneficial ideas for Humanity
and yet that can't get a grip on people
yet you know this victim mentality this
refusing to see the world refusing to
acknowledge reality
um has got a grip on people and just
just as a side point as well and the
whole thing about obesity City falls
into that you know the way they're
promoting obesity and you know why are
they doing this so depending on which
idea pathogen we're talking about the
answer to the why might be different
let's take for example obesity okay to
focus uh on on a particular uh idiotic
idea and look I use I I growing up I was
always incredibly thin I was a very
competitive soccer player and then over
the next 20 25 years I put on tons of
weight so much so that two and a half
three years ago uh you know I weighed in
at well over 200 pounds and then I
decided that I wanted to do something
about it and I lost tons of weight and
this is why I've now returned to the
status of Adonis uh that which of course
you're going to agree with I agree
absolutely Adonis
now I could have easily done the
following thing I could have followed
the Lisa lizzle not Liesel lizzle model
right which is I'm grossly overweight I
can do one of two things I can do all of
the hard work which is to assume
personal agency and personal
responsibility and you know starve
myself
for a year so that I can lose all this
weight exercise or I can argue that it's
a complete medical conspiracy that
obesity results in Downstream negative
effects on my health and it's it's a
complete social construction that men
don't like 800 pound women if only we
can convince men through better media
images that you know their fantasies lie
in in you know having sex with 800 pound
women then I would be loved right well
it's a lot easier for me again to go
back to the earlier point when I said
that people are cognitive misers people
are never mind that they're
intellectually lazy most people are just
inherently lazy about anything right so
I've got two choices either I assume a
victimology uh mindset which is not very
difficult to do or I starve myself for
the next year and a half I lost by the
way 86 pounds okay wow now you would
think and certainly someone at my age
right it's not I'm 20 my metabolism is
slower you would think it's pretty
difficult to lose that weight but well
it is very difficult but if you're
sufficiently committed and you do so on
every single day eventually one day you
get on the scale and you're the perfect
weight that you're supposed to be at so
now incidentally to continue with the
Obesity example uh I have a chapter in
the in not a chapter a section in the
book called all roads lead to bigotry
and let me explain what I mean by that
so if I am grossly overweight as a woman
I can argue that any state of the world
demonstrates that people are fattest
okay they're they're bigoted against
overweight people if a guy says I'm
uniquely attracted to overweight women
then the answer will be well you are
fetishizing my fat folds and I hate the
fact that you only find me sexually
attractive because I'm 800 pounds so
that's what so if I'm attracted to you
because you're fat it's bad and you're a
victim if I'm not attracted to you
because you're fat if I say I
specifically am not sexually attracted
to 800 pound women and would rather you
know have sex with women that have the
hourglass figure well then you are a
fattest because it is society that
taught you to not be attracted so so if
I'm attracted to fat women I'm a Nazi
and if I'm not attracted to fat women
I'm a Nazi exactly and so to answer your
question I mean to kind of summarize
what I said uh it's a lot easier for
people to be victims right it's a lot
easier now let's take the the general
victimology thing of uh you know we were
slaves 300 years ago or indigenous
people were mistreated 200 years ago I'm
not
I'm not uh
minimizing those historical grievances
but I don't need to go 300 years ago to
talk about grievances I put on running
shoes and ran really quickly as an 11
year old so that my head was not
detached from the rest of my body I
don't need to reference even my
Holocaust uh you know tribe members
that's only 75 years ago I experienced
it my parents were kidnapped by fatah
and tortured right my my wife's family
escaped Lebanon also before that they
escaped turkey in the Armenian Genocide
and yet we don't wallow in victimology
because we recognize that this is an
inherent part of our history we
recognize it it's part of who we are but
then we say you know what's going to
make us successful is if we overcome
that tragic start to life that we had
and here I stand with the lovely Layla
Leia having a conversation I could have
been wallowing in a corner crying boo
hoo hoo they did this to me when I was
11. and again I'm not suggesting that
you shouldn't own and and you know
accept the victimology that you've had
but move past it but regrettably it has
become orgiastic
to wallow in victimology and and I have
a section in the parasitic mind where I
talk about Munchausen Syndrome which
might be able to answer your original
question of what's the deal with all
this victimology the idea to to offer
that theory came to me from a 2010 paper
that I had written in a scientific
journal it was in a medical journal
where I was talking about an
evolutionary explanation for Munchausen
Syndrome by proxy let me explain two
things Munchausen syndrome is basically
it's a psychiatric disorder whereby
someone feigns a medical illness in
order to Garner empathy and sympathy
right there's an orgiastic need for for
people to be coming to me say oh poor
you poor you so even if I'm not sick I
will fake being sick so that I can get
that from you that's called Munchausen
Syndrome Munchausen Syndrome by proxy is
even more diabolical in that I take
someone who's under my care my pet my
elderly parent but most commonly my
biology logical child and I harm them so
that I can get the empathy and sympathy
by proxy and so I had written this paper
in 2010 and it it it stayed there and
then as I was writing the parasitic mind
and I was trying to explain
what is it that makes it at the
collective level so alluring for
everybody to be competing in victimology
scores I said aha it's Collective
Munchausen and Collective Munchausen by
proxy so the original Genesis of that
idea came to me in that 2010 paper which
I then extended now to the current
Zeitgeist I hope I've answered your
question yeah you haven't it makes a lot
of sense um the thing which still
confuses me because because I understand
you know people don't want to take
personal response take personal
responsibility I understand you know
people the attention that comes when
you're a victim and when you you know
you need someone to care for you and all
these sorts of things I get that
um but you know what kind of um makes me
uncomfortable is when these ideas are
pushed by politicians so AOC for example
I saw her once tweet um and she called
the Republican Party um the personal
responsibility party like as if it's bad
to take personal responsibility
um so that that's a question that I have
why why would they pretend that it's bad
to take personal responsibility and do
you think at any point there are
actually politicians and people at the
top who understand what is happening and
yet still push this agenda despite
knowing that it's actually bad yeah so
I'll take your last Point first uh
that's a great question because I often
ask myself that which and so I'll just
rephrase what you said do you truly
believe in your [ __ ] and the Deep
recesses of your mind or is just this
performative and you know I I kind of
oscillate at times I say to myself that
they have to ultimately believe it in
some form or another otherwise they
wouldn't be as good charlatans as they
truly are because so there's let me do a
little parenthesis a tangential thing
there is a theory in evolutionary
psychology that speaks to the idea of
why is it that humans have evolved the
capacity for self-deception why are we
so good at lying to our ourselves and
the the gentleman The evolutionary
biologist who offered an explanation
his name is Robert trivers it's a
brilliant explanation and the argument
goes like this Leia so if I am trying
you and I are involved in an
evolutionary arms race I'm trying to
dupe you into going into the back of the
cabin with me and you're trying to gauge
whether I'm an honest uh shooter right
and so so as I evolve better strategies
at you know manipulating you you evolve
counter strategies hence the
evolutionary so what's a counter
strategy that you're evolving well you
want to read cues of duplicity in me you
want to read my face or my or tonality
or the the subtle things that I'm saying
to gauge whether I am truthful or not
now one of the ways that I can shut off
those cues that otherwise would be
showing that I am lying to you is if I
first believe it myself so the First Act
of being able to manipulate you better
Leia is if I can convince my myself of
the lie because now when you're looking
at my eyes to pick up on those cues of
duplicity you won't find them because
I've actually lied to myself first so
it's a brilliant Theory and so to your
question I think that uh occasional
cortex AOC now there's by the way
there's a debate going occasional cortex
there is a debate as to who came up with
that term apparently there's a radio
host called Michael Savage unbeknownst
to me has been using that term I'm here
to repeat again it is the independent
humor of godsad that came up with
occasional I've written papers in
Neuroscience so I understand the cortex
so no I cannot steal it from my
copyrighted after the show exactly so so
whether it be occasional cortex or
whether it be the the cackler in Chief
uh uh Kamala Harris or whoever I think
that they find a way to believe those
things so that they could be better
purveyors of [ __ ] to the morons
you know that they're speaking to
so that would um that would imply that
they are actively trying to deceive
though
I I I think so right because ultimately
politicians are in the game of power and
uh the more people that I can control
and have under my Dominion the more or
geostatically pleasurable it is and
therefore I don't like the idea of you
assuming personal responsibility and
personal agency because the more freedom
and personal agency you have the less I
have dominion over your life so I think
in this very grotesque manner uh yes it
is it is duplicitous and it is willful
and so on yeah that's also what I agree
I have a very cynical
um Outlook unfortunately and I
definitely do think it's done to keep to
keep people under the thumb and keep
them down um I think control is always
the ultimate goal
um something which I think is really
interesting is the cognitive dissonance
that took over over the last two and a
half nearly three years I don't want to
say the words in case YouTube takes it
down or things with you know spreading
ill misinformation or anything like that
you know
um but what really fascinates me is the
way people have adopted these ideas like
it's a religion
um so do you think to some extent I know
obviously Society is become far more
secular than it ever was
um do you think to some extent people
are replacing these um replacing God
replacing religion with these weird
ideologies in order to you know give
their life some form of meaning
Direction and purpose uh I do and and
there are several ways that we can draw
an analogy between a you know standard
religion and the woke religion so for
example the idea of revealed truths that
are sacred that are sacrosanct that
you're not allowed to challenge well of
course that's Central in religion right
I mean in religious Dogma you know why
is my why is the truth in my book the
truth because it's written in my book
and therefore it's a tautology Circle
right don't question it right and so by
a similar type of parasitic Dogma you're
not allowed to question certain
realities so if you had said uh is it is
it Ellen Page that's become Elliot page
that I get those two things right okay
so remember when I can't remember who it
was that was canceled because they
Miss what is the term that that name is
misgendered they use the dead name oh
that's a weird thing that I've recently
just come across yeah yeah so how could
it be that in the 21st century that the
the the species that can land people on
the moon and that can solve Fermat's
Last Theorem and pure mathematics and
that can map the human genome can get
someone canceled because of what we just
talked about that's absolutely insane
but that's that's what's happening it's
uh and I mean that by the way that's
speaking of purpose and meaning that's
one of the things when I wake up in the
day I mean there are there are many
things that give me purpose and meaning
but one of which is that as a professor
I view it as my innate responsibility to
fight back against untruths and so when
I wake up in the morning I I literally
kind of rub my hands together who am I
going to God Smack into Oblivion today I
do it not because you know I'm this uh
you know uh irreverent contrarian who
just wants to cause trouble it's because
I'm genuinely offended by [ __ ] it
really bothers me when I see these half
truths these falsehoods it's an attack
on human reason on human dignity and so
oftentimes people say well you know you
when I meet you in person you seem so
much warmer warmer and friendlier and
how you are on social media well it's
not because
my disposition has changed it's just
because on social media there are so
many imbeciles and morons that even
though I can be patient 99 of the time
that one percent where somebody gets
under my skin then you'll see me as
being too spicy in my retort and so on
but the reality is it's part of my
personhood to fight back when I hear
untruths
yeah I actually get the same response
I'm very nice in person but on social
media I I'm also I'm also offended I'm
hurt you know I'm also offended when I
see um you know there's this boy that's
gone viral boy I don't know trans girl
um called Dylan who's basically it's
it's not blackface but it's like Woman
face he's just he's just trivializing
everything it means to be a woman and
laughing and all this stuff and you know
it's it's really not that simple being a
woman so I'm like sit down you know
but it's but but yeah it's crazy and and
I do think that it is a replacement of
religion because I feel like especially
over the last two years with the masks
um a lot of a lot of the time we we live
in such a pathetic Society where
everybody's getting participation
trophies and so they have nothing to
feel proud of other than I'm gonna wear
my mask because I'm adding value to
society I'm contributing because they've
never contributed for once in their life
to any decent cause yeah 100 instead of
speaking about uh the mask and the covet
a couple of weeks ago I had uh I don't
know are you familiar with the Great
Barrington declaration do you know what
that is I'm not uh it was it was a open
letter that was uh written by three uh
professors
questioning some of the Draconian covet
policies that had been put in place
right now all so one of those co-authors
came on my show his name is Jay
batasharia and it's astonishing that in
the 21st century he's a professor of
medicine and professor of Health
economics at Stanford right so it's not
as though he's lacking in credentials
but if you see how this gentleman
gentleman and true scholar highly
accomplished scholar if you see how he
was demonized by the the the the mask
religious people it's just it's just
unbelievable to think that this is where
our discourse is which basically in a
sense speaks to the continuity of how
easy we are to be parasitized as a human
species it speaks to my earlier point
which is yes today today we are
succumbing to particular idea pathogens
but the fact that human beings can be
parasitized has been with us since time
immemorial and so it's it's very
disheartening because my original
training uh as a doctoral student was in
psychology of decision making and I
studied things like rational Choice
behavior and so rationality has been at
the root of my doctoral training and to
see us now completely depart from any
semblance of rationality and people
consider that laudable is very
disheartening and this is why I fight
Leia I can understand that can you
explain to me how the cognitive
dissonance works because over the last
two years the the weirdest one for me
was my body my choice
um you know that's what we've been
drilled into our heads but then when it
comes to taking the magic medicine no
it's it's your body my choice so how
does that cognitive dissonance work like
how do you get there yeah so
prior to answering that specific example
cognitive dissonance of course is itself
a very alluring trap across many domains
so as someone who studies consumer
psychology when we make a purchase so
I'm about to choose between Toyota or
Mazda and I decide to buy the Mazda the
mere fact that I've now signed the
contract to buy the Mazda cognitive
dissonance sets in because oh I think I
should have chosen Toyota right now what
we then end up doing in this case as
consumers is we
implements some cognitive strategies to
assuage our cognitive dissonance so for
example if I see any incoming
information that supports the decision
that I've made I will amplify it in my
head if I see any information that is
contrary to the final decision I make
then I will discount the veracity of
that information oh it's my uncle who
said this and he's a [ __ ] everybody
knows that he's a drunk and so therefore
there are all sorts of cognitive
strategies that I can use to assuage
that internal inconsistency In My Head
by the way the the the pioneer of
cognitive dissonance theory is a very uh
well-known social psychologist named
Leon festinger so for those of you who
want to look up so that's the original
uh you know Genesis of
dissonance theory so but to your point I
think people are perfectly happy to be
irrational and hold completely
cognitively inconsistent beliefs in
their head as long as it fits the a
political Dogma that they are ascribing
to so to me it doesn't surprise me in
the least bit that they're doing exactly
what you're saying that's part and
parcel of the human Spirit regrettably
that's so fascinating because if I if I
see myself
um contradicting myself I will then
like like check in with myself and think
oh hang on I need to reassess My Views
that means because you're intellectually
honest and I think most people are not
uh you know I let's take that Honesty to
an extreme form so I'm I'm someone who
is maladaptively perfectionist okay so
for example when I get when I receive
the galley proofs of my latest books The
Galley proofs is sort of the final
version that you have one more chance to
go over to make sure that there are no
errors well I go into a complete uh
panic because I'm now worried what if
there is a comma that is misplaced
somewhere that I missed so I have a very
purist band and that allows me to then
exactly do what you did which is I'm
always very clean cognitively if I see
any inconsistencies I'm gonna do exactly
what you said that you do which is I'm
gonna work through them so that my
edifice of uh you know justifications
from my positions are very clean or
going back earlier my normal logical
network is very very tight it's
unassailable but again that takes
intellectual honesty and it also takes
intellectual humility because if you
identify a cognitive inconsistency in
you it means that somewhere you went
wrong and that you're willing to admit
that you went wrong but of course if
you're dogmatic especially when it comes
to these hot button political issues uh
you know Dogma overrules intellectual
honesty and therefore la la I don't want
to hear about my my cognitive
inconsistencies that's so fascinating um
yeah it is to do with being
intellectually honest I I do it a lot um
and I have an example but it's a whole
can of worms which I won't get into but
I'll just briefly I'll very very briefly
tell you a story very briefly
um I try to actually move
um to Israel when I was a couple years
ago in in the heart of the pandemic and
um long story short I wasn't vaccinated
um and I got treated very badly by a
bunch of different um locals and um what
happened was I basically nearly ended up
homeless one night because I wasn't
vaccinated so I couldn't get a hotel
so I then had a had a had an epiphany
moment which was like I'm in a country
that's happy to discriminate against me
because I'm unvaccinated
wow I was like [ __ ] what does that mean
about everything that I've heard in the
news
about this country you know
uh discriminating against certain people
for the greater good of Greater reasons
blah blah blah blah
but that moment for me I was like now
I'm on the other side of the
discrimination
and that was a hard moment for me like
that's not my my reality chattered well
first thank you so much for sharing that
personal story but
was it shortly thereafter that you
decided Israel is not for me and I need
to look for other pastors
um I gave it I gave it like
it gave it six more weeks okay I found I
found a place I actually stayed at a
random man's house he let me in he lived
with his mum he was like a promise it's
safe I live with my mother
I was like okay so I stayed and my dad
spoke to him on the phone my dad speaks
Hebrew it was fine but you know it was
it was it was that moment that I was
like
yeah that's when I the the intellectual
honesty really set in and I was like I
need to reevaluate the way I look at
everything now
wow and so all of the incredibly
handsome uh military guys wearing their
Commando suits did not
tilt you towards staying in Israel
apparently if I was 18 years old yes not
in my 20s not in my mid-20s when I'm a
lot more intelligent it's interesting
that you say this because it speaks by
the way to an evolutionary fact which is
that there are certain mating attributes
that we view as as terribly important at
one stage in our life that become less
important or vice versa and you're
speaking exactly to that point so that
makes sense yeah like The evolutionary
thing which I think is like the most
important is a mutual agreed mentality
that freedom above everything else yeah
that's key yeah like if you if you if
you're happy to like you know bend over
daddy daddy government and do what they
say just so that you can you know live
freely I can't to me that's quite
dangerous and so that's that's what I
saw a lot of over there and I thought
yeah wow I'm a different person now to
who I was like five years ago but and by
the way I mean your your point about
sort of a sorting on on those
fundamental beliefs is is support
supported by the scientific literature
specifically your viewers might be
interested in knowing this that so there
are two competing ideas one is birds of
a feather flock together or opposites
attract and it turns out that over the
long term if what you're looking for is
the likelihood of your union being
successful over the long term say a
marriage then it's overwhelmingly birds
of a feather flock together that
predicts that reality that's actually
something that I discussed in my next
book uh because in the next book I talk
about uh you know how to live the good
life because people always say you you
always seem to be smiling you're like
the Happy Professor what's the secret
and so I said you know what let me write
my attempt of explaining what makes me
happy and what is the root of happiness
and so one of the things I talk about is
choosing the right spouse and in there I
talk about the fact that it is
fundamentally important to choose
someone uh on with whom the fundamental
values that Define your everyday life
you share them if if not you're likely
to fail
that's so fascinating so yeah I want to
hear this so what are you working on now
um and can we hear a little bit more
about this book because yeah everybody
wants to know how to how to be with a
smile 24 7. so what's the secret so uh
so so the book is is I mean I think
it'll it's going to end up being the the
final title it's the sad truth about
happiness sad of course s-a-d and uh I
actually just earlier today I was
speaking to the publisher we had
different possibilities for the book
cover but I think they want to go with a
just an actual photo of me uh smiling uh
since many people see me as that uh so
what do I do in the book I basically
argue that there are
certain decisions that we can take and
certain mindsets that we can adopt that
augment the likelihood of us living a
you know a happy life now part of it by
the way cannot be under your control
because part of it is just dispositional
you you know some people are happier
than others and now I was fortunate
enough to to be born with a sunny
disposition but that only covers about
50 percent of if you like your happiness
score so the good news is that there's
still a big big chunk that is within
your personal agency that that you could
change so what are some of these so in
terms of uh decisions that you can take
that either impart great misery or great
happiness one is certainly choosing the
right spouse and and two is choosing a
profession that grants you that purpose
and meaning and I argue in the book that
a sure path to feeling fulfilled is to
be in professions where your creative
impulse can be instantiated aided
because the creative impulse whether it
be I'm creating a Dish as a chef or I'm
creating a bridge as an architect or I'm
creating content as you are as a podcast
host
there is something quite uh exhilarating
about something not having been there
before you came along and then through
your creative impulse this comes about
so I talk about that but then I also
discuss a whole bunch of mindsets that
can either increase our happiness or not
and by the way many people might say
well there's probably no topic that's
been written about more than how to be
happy what are you going to add well
what I'm going to add is my unique story
and then backed up with science as I see
it so so trust me there's all kinds of
Novel stuff in there let me mention a
few so I talk about at one point about
uh
Life as a playground as a as a mindset
of how to live life so uh people say but
you know don't doesn't it demean you
when you when you joke around as this
fancy Professor no it doesn't right
because I can both be the austere
serious Professor who speaks at Stanford
University as I did to to weeks ago and
I can also be the satirist who hides
under my desk uh satirically because I
am very comfortable in my personhood
that I don't have to put a false Aura of
profundity so that you could take me
seriously as a professor when I do my
research it's a form of play the
research is very serious but what
greater play is there than to uncover
relationships between patterns and
nature that's science right so in the
same way that a child solves a puzzle
well science is just one big
epistemological puzzle so I could even
tackle science with a playful twinkle in
my eye and so
so that would be an example I'll give
you maybe one or two others you tell me
when you want me to stop no no this is
great I think I'll just quickly say
um when you're talking about you know
balancing being serious versus
um being satirical I think um I think
that balance is beautiful I think it's
like a I think I think it's very
endearing actually a lot of um people
that that are you know doctors
professors and all these things they
often remain serious all the time and
it's it's unpleasant actually
um I think you managed to spread your
message in a much more effective way by
by being more relatable because you're
not serious all the time so yeah I think
it's very endearing oh that's lovely for
you to say and you know it's funny
because when I get a I mean I get
approached often in the street and
sometimes I'm taken aback by how
friendly and familiar people are but
then I realize it's precisely because of
that because people feel like you're
their friend people and I like that I
don't want to be the you know Dr sad
don't approach him I mean that means my
message is resonating I mean you and I
are in the business of hopefully
creating stuff that makes people happy
that challenges them that they say my
God I I benefited so much from listening
to Leia this past hour so I want you to
come up to me and and be nice and be
sweet and I'm never blase about people
coming up to me so I appreciate you
saying that okay a couple of more uh one
of the things I talk about is uh variety
seeking uh you know as a as a as a
mindset that can give you happiness but
of course like all things in life uh
in some instances variety seeking can
can be condemned so for as I talk in the
book about sexual variety seeking food
variety seeking and intellectual variety
seeking well to the first one sexual
variety seeking it might be a problem
when you're in a monogamous Union and so
how do you navigate the the tension
between our innate pension to seek
variety and certain moral contracts that
we have signed on to that that don't
condone that so I talk about that I'll
do one more if you'd like uh I talk
about uh so the ancient Greeks talked
about everything in moderation right the
idea that too little of something is not
good too much of something is not good
Aristotle himself in in his FX book
talked about the soldier if the soldier
is too reckless in his courage then he's
an idiot because he's gonna die and of
course if he's too cowardly then he's
not a good soldier somewhere in the
middle lies The Sweet Spot and so I have
a chapter on explaining how everything
in life is driven by that equation so
for example how the incent the intensity
with which I exercise turns out to be
optimal at a moderate level if I
exercise at two lower level or to a high
level it's less good than if I exercise
at a moderate level uh how much
consumption of different types of foods
all follows the inverted you too little
is not good too much is not and so
I have many many other such examples so
basically the book is a completely novel
way of looking at how to climb if you'd
like to mount happiness hopefully if
I've done a good job it will get me to
buy a house right next to yours in Miami
well I can't wait to read it that sounds
amazing especially a bit about picking a
spouse and how you do that God that's a
nightmare so I can't wait to read it
um how can people follow everything that
you're doing you know check out other
books that you have how can people keep
in touch with you uh thanks for asking
uh so on Twitter I'm at Gad
g-a-d-s-a-a-d I have a public Facebook
page I don't remember the URL but it's
not difficult to get uh I'm on Instagram
uh I'm I also have my own personal
website godsad.com uh I've got the
YouTube channel which two years ago I
then also now made it into a podcast
because a lot of people kept complaining
that they don't want to sit there in
front of YouTube streaming they want to
be jogging and listening to my
malefuous deep voice while they're
walking and so about two years ago I
started the podcast so there's all sorts
of places you could connect with me send
me an email I try to read all of them
not sure if I could answer all of them
but I would love to hear from folks
amazing is there anything else you'd
like to share that I haven't asked or
that I haven't covered uh no uh simply
uh I'm envious of your Radiant phone I
wish that I was there with you in
beautiful Florida I know that many of my
friends who have moved to Florida most
notably Dave Rubin he doesn't lose an
opportunity to remind me that I need to
be moving to Florida ASAP so hopefully
one day from God from my lips to God's
ear I will be joining you at some beach
in Florida yeah you have to this is
truly one of the best places in the
world minus having to pay taxes but
better taxes than in um than in Canada
but no it's the best place everybody's
very like-minded it's such a pleasure to
be able to speak so freely and um not be
um around crazy work people um that's
why I like Florida
um but God I want to thank you so much
it's been such a pleasure um I've
learned so much from you and I'm really
really looking forward to your next book
I cannot wait to give it a read thank
you you're a delight thank you so much
for having me cheers thank you and
everyone please make sure to hit the
like button and subscribe and we'll see
you all next week bye bye the Leia hail
plan show
foreign